[Music]
foreign
daily cancellation we have another viral
Tick Tock video which has garnered
millions of views thousands of comments
lots of discussion it's the kind of
video that on first blush you might
think that I would hate and I sort of do
but it's not all bad um here we have a
gen Z or a Zoomer by the name of cat
complaining about how much harder it is
for young people today than it was for
her parents and her grandparents
generation and this message has as you
might expect resonated quite a bit with
her fellow gen ziers on Tick Tock
um let's listen to some of this so I'm
about to graduate in May a lot of the
conversations I've been having with my
parents lately have been surrounded what
I'm going to do and I graduate where I'm
going to go so my mom works for a
company that's just like huge and she
said something to me yesterday that
makes a lot of sense in regards to why
it's so hard to find a job or even to
find a salary right now that would be
livable as someone who's like fresh out
of college she said that a lot of the
people who are in charge of hiring their
commonly say things like college grads
expect way too much or I didn't have
that much when I graduated then she says
yeah when I first started I made 36 000
and I was like thirty six thousand
dollars today or thirty six thousand
dollars in 1980. so she made thirty six
thousand starting off entry level bank
teller in 1980. right now out of college
I want to make 24 an hour that would put
me at fifty thousand dollars a year
which is equivalent to having a sixteen
thousand five hundred dollar salary in
1982. so I did some research the average
college grad in 2022 is making fifty
five thousand two hundred sixty dollars
in 1982 the average college grad was
making 102 200 dollars right out of
college so today 26.50 an hour is 1982
it's 49 an hour so this sentiment being
held by Boomers of oh well they're just
expecting too much I just don't think
they know what numbers they're talking
about like I think in their head they're
like oh I made 36 000 in 1980 and you're
asking for 50 000 now so then I dug a
little deeper started looking at housing
apartments in 2022 the median selling
price for a single family house was five
hundred seven thousand eight hundred
dollars in 1980 that same price is
equivalent to today's 223 202 in 2022
the average rent for a one bedroom
apartment was Nineteen hundred dollars
in 1982 that same number was equivalent
to today's 737 dollars like I actually
think that Boomers just can't
conceptualize how vastly different these
numbers are
okay so we'll pause it here to
acknowledge that she's basically correct
about everything that you said so far
there's simply no denying that money had
more value more purchasing power 40
years ago than it does today jobs
generally paid more when measured in
today's dollars and things didn't cost
as much
um in fact by nearly every conceivable
measure economically societally
culturally the Boomers inherited a
better country than they'll leave behind
for their children
um they inherited Prosperity they leave
stagnation and decline in debt and
bankruptcy they inherited a vibrant and
patriotic culture they leave us one that
is rotten and degenerate they inherited
strong nuclear families and they leave
behind a long sad trail of divorce and
broken homes
as a generation they failed to do the
one single thing that every generation
is supposed to do which is to create a
better world for their children it
doesn't have to be a Utopia it will
never be that but it should be better a
generation's only Legacy is the country
it leaves behind and judging by that one
and only real metric the Boomers have
catastrophically failed and they're not
done either
they're still clinging to their
positions of leadership in DC and media
and Corporate America they've made for
some of the worst political leaders this
country has ever seen
and they refuse to go away
they refuse to ride off into the sunset
and let us clean up the mess that in in
this this is this is a problem it's all
absolutely true there's no getting
around it
Boomers generally don't take this kind
of criticism well well but um that
doesn't stop them from complaining
bitterly about Millennials and gen Z
what they like to ignore or maybe have
somehow forgotten is that Millennials
and gen Z are their children and
grandchildren that's all part of their
legacy the millennial generation my
generation
we didn't Sprout from the ground
randomly like fungus we didn't fall out
of the sky like snowflakes we were
conceived and and birthed and raised
and in many cases raised poorly
in fact raised may be an overstatement
many Millennials were less raised than
they were merely sustained with food and
toys and television and then sent out
into the world with no moral or
spiritual formation whatsoever
now speaking in generalizations of
course but they are accurate
generalizations and anyway Millennials
uh fall victim to generalizations all
the time so perhaps it's time for some
other generations to get a dose of that
medicine I think it's it's important to
speak about the cataclysmic failures of
the boomer generation and to hold them
accountable for instilling in
Millennials every negative trait that
they now so eagerly complain about
and that's important to point out not to
Simply cast blame but because it's it's
not it's not just or honest to give your
children a destroyed culture a
bankrupted country
and then immediately blamed them for it
did you know that our friends at genucel
have upgraded their most popular package
to feature their top selling deep
firming vitamin C serum plus Ultra
retinol moisturizer with natural retinol
alternative I bet you didn't know that
but now you do right now you can take
advantage of this limited time package
uh for 70 percent off why waste time and
money to go get work done on your face
when you can get genucel skin care
shipped right to your door join yourself
secret is a family recipe for over 20
years that makes it safe for all skin
types and perfect for both men and women
made by a compounding pharmacist in
small batches and is always safe cruelty
free and natural you know my hair makeup
artist Cherokee is a lot like a lizard
any chance she gets she'll be out laying
on a rock sunbathing in the middle of a
desert somewhere but to make sure she
doesn't have skin that looks as cracked
and Dusty as the desert ground she uses
genucel's wide range of products to keep
her skin looking young go to
juniorcell.com's most popular package
for 70 off featuring genucel's Ultra
retinal and genucel's Firming Serum as
well you get a complimentary Spa
Essentials box with every package order
plus a free upgrade to priority shipping
you get all of that you can get it now
but you got to go to genucel.com Walsh
that's genucel.com Welsh
you know if we're ever going to break
this cycle and really combat the
diseases of entitlement and materialism
and selfishness then we have to inspect
the origins of the problem of course the
Boomers no more created selfishness than
did Millennials or then did gen Z but
they did create a culture that
encourages and breeds this stuff they
created this culture by prioritizing
material wealth and personal comfort and
Rapid gratification over everything
basically they relied on the schools in
Hollywood to take charge of their kids
while they amassed the kind of Financial
Security their kids will never know
if a child is going to grow to be
unselfish you must learn to be a part of
something bigger than himself something
that requires effort and self-denial and
active sacrificial love a strong nuclear
family is such a thing the church is
such a thing but the Boomers who sent
the divorce rates skyrocketing into the
Stars largely failed to give their kids
the necessary Foundation of a nuclear
family
and they certainly didn't invest their
kids in the church or faith or
spirituality entertainment and material
possessions served as replacements for
both of those things
but entertainment and material
possessions are self-serving by Design
they will not help a child come out of
himself they'll only send him spiraling
deeper and deeper into the abyss of his
own ego
now
I have at this point strayed rather far
from the point that the girl in Tick
Tock was trying to make but it's all
related and these are all valid points
but um from there she kind of goes
somewhat off the rail so let's keep
listening
and I think Boomers just have such a
hard time conceptualizing this because
they never had to fight for jobs they
were at the upswing of Technology they
were at the upswing of big business
capitalism was Boomin and then they look
at us and they're thinking entitled and
I'm not saying anyone's like in the
right or in the wrong it's not their
fault like they just don't know
literally just don't know what the
I'm gonna do when I graduate and anytime
I talk to my parents both of which are
boomers they're like
stop having such high expectations also
I don't want to see any comments about
well you should have majored in computer
science or you should have majored in
medicine I think that if you go to
college you deserve to be able to make
enough to live comfortably I think if
you don't go to college you should be
able to make enough to live comfortably
regardless your major regardless if you
chose to go to college or not you
deserve to live comfortably so anyone
who says that your path to success
should have looked differently they're
probably just not able to conceptualize
the reality of today's job market and
the reality of how much it costs to go
to school nowadays
okay we were doing so well but then the
Gen zitis kicked in and she started
babbling about what she deserves now I I
honestly don't know what a statement
like I deserve to live comfortably means
to deserve something is to earn it it's
to be worthy of it are we all worthy of
a comfortable life have we earned it
just by simply existing
and even if we have even if we do all
deserve Comfort whatever that means what
good does it do for you to to just talk
about how you deserve it you can cry all
you want about what you think you
deserve but to quote Clint Eastwood in
Unforgiven and also a Snoop from The
Wire deserve ain't got nothing to do
with it
now maybe we all deserve to skip through
fields of daffodils while gun drop gum
drops fall from the sky but that's not
what life has presented us okay that's
that's not the reality
so maybe you deserve something other
than the reality I don't know what that
means
you can't manifest what you think you
deserve just by talking about it and
making demands to the universe
so for all the younger people who lament
the state of things and the fact that in
many ways it would have been easier to
have been to have been born 40 years ago
uh we might just put it this way
you're right
you get a raw deal
it's not fair
um I don't think you deserve a
comfortable life necessarily life is
simply an uncomfortable thing much of
the time but you do deserve a better
country and a better culture and a
better economy than the one that you're
getting
okay
now what we've established that
okay it's like it shouldn't be this way
this should this should not be the
culture that you are inheriting
it's it shouldn't be
but
okay what's your next move what do you
do now
the problem with people in the younger
generation is that they they correctly
diagnose many of these issues and then
they use that diagnosis as an excuse to
give up before the game even starts
they decide not to put in the effort at
work they decide not to work hard they
decide to essentially drop out of the
dating scene and give up on romantic
relationships and marriage and family
and everything they Retreat behind
phones and screens and this is just not
the way to solve any of these problems
it's the same kind of criticism that I
have of the red pill manosphere types
who correctly point out all the ways the
system is stacked against men but then
they offer no real solution except for a
full-scale retreat recommending that men
give up on Family Life marriage Legacy
their own bloodline
that's not a strategy that's despair
and you can't give in to despair
especially at a young age
so yes you may graduate from college
and realize that you wasted a lot of
time and money on a useless degree
um
you got scammed into going to college
when you really didn't need to go and
you you plunged yourself into debt for
something that might not do you any good
at all
that's also really unfair it shouldn't
have happened but it did
uh you may struggle to attain Financial
Security
you may not be able to afford a house or
many of the things that your parents
could afford at your age
all of that may be the case
these are the obstacles that you face
every generation has its own okay it's
not perfect for anybody
and these are yours
the goal is to succeed and thrive in
spite of them
that must be the goal otherwise there is
no point
you have to get to work either way and
obsessing over how unfair everything is
and how you aren't being handed what you
think you deserve will not accomplish
anything
you have to work for it one way or
another otherwise you are today canceled
and I'll do it for this portion of shows
and move over to the members block hope
to see you there if not talk to you uh
tomorrow Godspeed